good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
studying today is SCP 178 object class
Euclid special containment procedures
SCP 178 is to be stored in a class three
anomalous object container guarded by no
fewer than two armed personnel with
level three clearance when not
undergoing testing item is to be removed
from containment only with written
permission of personnel with level four
clearance or higher following incident
178 14 alpha all tests are to be
monitored remotely in the presence of
all personnel apart from test subjects
in the testing area during
experimentation is expressly prohibited
[Music]
description SCP 178 is a pair of white
stereoscopic 3d glasses with a
rectangular white cardboard frame and
lenses of transparent blue and red left
and right lenses respectively plastic
the item exhibits no unusual physical
properties apart from a slight
discoloration of the cardboard
consistent with age when worn the wearer
begins perceiving large bipedal entities
in addition to its ordinary surroundings
entities reportedly exhibit a docile and
occasionally curious behavior reports
include entities leaning over the
shoulder of persons working and
observing them with interest with one
exception any attempt by the wearer or
any other personnel the incident report
178 14 alpha to directly interact with
the entity's results in severe
lacerations suddenly appearing on
persons involved the appearance of
lacerations is rapid and continues until
the moment the wearer expires the
pattern of lacerations is always
consistent with being slashed with three
parallel tapered sharp objects of
lengths varying between fourteen point
two and twenty seven point four
centimeters and maximum thickness
varying between two point nine and eight
point one centimeters
recording and measuring devices used
during testing failed to detect any
anomalies including while lacerations
were appearing on subjects subjects do
not report hearing any sounds emanating
from the entity's long-term observation
of subjects exposed to the item reveals
no lasting effects stereoscopic images
viewed through the item appear
three-dimensional addendum one item was
recovered on in Tennessee by agent
operating as a deep-cover agent in the
US Fish and Wildlife Service who arrived
in the town following reports of a
year-old child being found dead in her
second-floor bedroom apparently as a
result of an unusual mauling
agent noticed the blood-stained
stereoscopic image of a ferris wheel
adjacent to where the child was
discovered after some searching found
the item under the child's bed where it
had apparently been thrown during the
child's death throes agent then
proceeded to call a recovery team to his
location following the recovery team's
arrival agent wore the item and looked
at the image reporting nothing unusual
until he turned his head to his left
whereupon he noticed an entity
approximately an inch from his face
leaning over his shoulder and looking at
the stereoscopic image in the debriefing
agents reported also noticing several
other entities in the room observing him
and the recovery team agent refrained
from attempting to interact with the
entities and the item was recovered
without incident
addendum to all experiments are to be
logged in file 178 e experiment 178 e
one name doctor with doctors and doctors
assisting date 19 procedure d-class
subject is to be placed in secure test
chamber containing SCP 178 the test
chamber is to be observed via
bulletproof glass window to adjacent
control room and via audio and video
recording devices d-class subject will
be instructed to wear a CP 178 and
report what it observes until told
otherwise results subject D 1 7 8 3 1
male
41 no discernible mental abnormalities
is placed in the chamber until to wear
SCP 178 subject is not told of scp-172
nature subject does as instructed then
immediately expresses distress by
throwing SCP 178 away and covering its
eyes while vocalizing fear research
staff instructs subject to describe the
source of its distress subject
unresponsive research staff attempts to
calm subject subject responds by
uncovering its face and looking around
appearing still to be distressed
research staff instructs the subject
once again to describe the source of its
distress subject responds by stating the
presence of an unfamiliar entity in
close proximity to its face the moment
at War SCP 178 research staff instructs
subject to describe the entity in detail
subject responds by stating entity was
hideous and had too many eyes research
staff instructs subject to describe the
entity in greater detail subject states
it did not manage to perceive many
details before removing SCP 178 research
staff instructs subject to where 178
subjects uncooperative research staff
repeats instruction subject
uncooperative research staff threatens
subject with termination unless it
cooperates subject uncool
operative testing is ended and subject
is placed under surveillance to test for
long-lasting symptoms of exposure
subject displays symptoms of mild
paranoia for two days before returning
to normal
behavioral patterns surveillance ended
after 30 days and subject terminated
note well this wasn't very informative
but at least it confirms we have an
actual anomalous object in our hands
experiment 178 II to name dr. with
doctors and doctors assisting date
nineteen
procedure d-class subject is to be
placed in secured test chamber
containing SCP 178 the test chamber is
to be observed by a bulletproof glass
window to adjacent control room and via
audio and video recording devices
d-class subject will be instructed to
wear a CP 178 and report what it
observes until told otherwise results
d63 164 female 31 no discernible mental
abnormalities is placed in the chamber
and instructed to wear SCP 178 subject
is not told of scp-172 true nature
subject does is instructed and
immediately begins omitting exploitive
x' and walking backwards towards the
chambers wall looking intently at
something - it's 1:00 o'clock
research staff instructs subject to
describe what it's seen subject presses
its back to chamber wall and describes
seeing an entity standing halfway across
the test chamber by the wall looking at
the wall research staff instructs
subject to describe the entity in detail
subject states the entity is bipedal
possesses two additional upper
appendages ending in large conical
protrusions and a smooth head research
staff instructs subject to provide
additional details subject begins
describing the entity and then suddenly
expresses distress stating oh god it's
looking right at me
subject collapses against the test
chamber wall still staring in the same
direction research staff inquires as to
whether the entity is exhibiting
hostility or not subject states that it
is not moving but looking at it subject
instructed to remove SCP 178 subject
refuses stating that it does not trust
the entity subject reminded that
uncooperative behavior will result in
termination subject removes SCP 178 and
begins looking around the test chamber
in distress stating that it can no
longer see the entity subject instructed
to wear SCP 178 subject complies and
states that the entity is still looking
at it
subject instructed to report any changes
in the entity's behavior two minutes and
37 seconds pass before subject states
the entity is no longer looking at it
subject states entity is looking at the
wall again subject reports no further
changes for 17 minutes and 55 seconds
test ended notes it seems strange that
the thing the subject saw was so
disinterested given the way the item
came into foundation attention we didn't
pick anything up in any of the recording
equipment either
I wonder if this entity is really there
or an illusion generated by the item
experiment 178 III named doctor with
doctors and doctors assisting date 19
procedure d-class
subject is to be placed in secured test
chamber containing SCP 178 the test
chamber is to be observed by a
bulletproof glass window to adjacent
control room and via audio and video
recording devices a fractal blue and red
image is to be placed on one wall of the
test chamber and a plastic bin
containing 10 standard tennis balls is
to be placed near the opposite wall
d-class subject will be told as CP 178
is an experiment in next-generation 3d
specs and that's staring at the fractal
image while wearing a CP 178 will allow
it to see animated three-dimensional
images d-class subject will then be
instructed to wear SCP 178 and report
what it observes in case the subject
perceives any entities it will be
instructed to throw a tennis ball at
them
results d5 1 4 4 1 male 27 arson murder
no discernible mental abnormalities is
instructed to stand at the end of the
test chamber opposite the fractal image
and whereas CP 178 subject complies and
expresses surprise and discomfort
subject instructed to describe what it
perceives subject states it perceives
two entities standing in the room one
from now on referred to as entity one
next to the fractal image with its back
to the subject and the other from now on
referred to as entity 2 crossing the
room from left to right subject Alpine's
that the person who designed the
animation is mentally unbalanced subject
instructed to describe entity twos gait
subject states it walks using both its
legs and upper appendages subject
acquaints entity 2's gait to that of a
gorilla if someone put its skeleton
together wrong research staff inquires
whether both entities are similar
subject replies that apart from size
they appear to be generally similar
subject then proceeds to describe
entities fitting the description of the
entity in experiment 178 a to subject
instructed to pick up one tennis ball
and throw it at entity to subject
complies both the research staff and the
awning recording devices observe the
ball moving uninterrupted until it hits
the floor on the opposite side of the
test chamber subject expresses surprise
and distress attempting to back away for
0.7 seconds before severe lacerations
begin appearing on its body appearance
of lacerations continues for 4.7 seconds
until subject presumably expires from
massive bleeding and trauma autopsy on
expired subject reveals lacerations
consistent with being slashed by three
sharp objects relatively thick and
tapering to a point approximately 17
centimeters in length and four
centimeters in maximum width analysis of
ball thrown by subject discovers only
trace amounts of human sweat matching
subject D five one four four
notes holy it would appear that these
things don't like being disturbed on the
other hand that ball sails through the
air like nothing was there and with the
death of the subject we cannot know if
it indeed passed where the entity was or
not this is still far from conclusive
but the pattern of laceration matches
the findings at the items recovery site
so at least we've established beyond any
doubt that it is dangerous it's
interesting to note that so far the
entities are pretty consistent in
appearance despite variance between test
subjects I wonder if any nonviolent
interaction between the subject and the
entities is possible experiment 178 e4
named dr. with dr. and dr. assisting
date 19th procedure d-class subject is
to be placed in secured test chamber
containing SCP 178 test chamber is to be
observed via bulletproof glass window
adjacent to control room via audio and
video recording devices via infrared
cameras electromagnetic radiation
sensors and motion detectors a fractal
blue and red image is to be placed on
one wall of the test chamber d-class
subject will be told
scp-172 8 is an experiment in next
generation 3d specs and that staring at
the fractal image while wearing a CP 178
will allow it to see 3-dimensional
images d-class subject will then be
instructed to wear a CP 178 and report
what it observes in case the subject
perceives any entities it will be
instructed to attempt to speak with them
results d8 for two nine one female 19 no
discernible mental abnormalities is
instructed to stand near the wall
opposite of the fractal image and where
is CP 178 subject complies and
immediately expresses revulsion subject
instructed to describe what it perceives
subject describes one entity similar to
those previously reported standing
approximately two meters from it and
looking at it
subject instructed to attempt to speak
to it subject appears confused as to why
it would attempt to speak to an animated
image research staff repeats instruction
subject expresses irritation and says
hello weird thing how are you today in a
bored manner lacerations begin appearing
on the subjects torso and abdomen 0.2
seconds after subject finishes speaking
subjects right arm severed above the
elbow after 2.4 seconds laceration and
subject vocalization stops after 8.4
seconds when the subject presumably
expires autopsy on expired subject
reveals the same kind of lacerations
indicating sharp objects approximately
21 centimeters in length and 5
centimeters in width notes I guess that
means we can assume that any attempt to
interact with the entities ends in
hostility and nothing on any of the
sensors either we're establishing a
pattern here but the main question is
still whether the death of the subjects
is caused by the item or by external
entities
I wonder if subjects not wearing the
item can be affected by it experiment
178 e 5 name dr. with doctors and
doctors assisting date 19 procedure 2
d-class subjects are to be placed in
secured test chamber containing SCP 178
the test chamber is to be observed via
bulletproof glass window to adjacent
control room via audio and video
recording devices via infrared cameras
electromagnetic radiation sensors and
motion detectors both subjects will have
general knowledge of the properties of
scp-172 signators subject 1 will be
instructed to wear SCP 178 and will
describe to the other subject designated
subject
to the location and appearance of any
perceived entities in the test chamber
subject two will then attempt to
interact with the entity's results
subject 1 d6 1 9 5 5 female 35 3 counts
of murder grievous bodily harm no
discernible mental abnormality and
subject to d5 7 3 2 1 female 27 no
discernible mental abnormalities are
placed in the test chamber subject 1
instructed to weigh our SCP 178 subject
one expresses dislike for the research
staff
subject 2 concurs research staff reminds
both subjects that uncooperative
behavior is grounds for termination
subject 1 where's SCP 178 and begins
emitting expletives subject to expresses
distress and inquires as to the reason
for subject ones consternation subject 1
states that there's one right behind you
subject 2 turns around in states that it
cannot see anything unusual research
staff comms both subjects by ensuring
them that the perceived entities are
harmless and instructs subject 1 to
assist subject to in making contact with
the entities subject 1 states that there
is an entity about a foot in front of
her and that the entity's head is about
2 feet taller than her subject 2
inquires whether the entity is looking
at it subject 1 replies in the
affirmative subject 2 attempts to calm
itself and proceeds to look where it
considers the entity's head to be and
say hi there lacerations immediately
began appearing on subject twos torso
and face 4 0.9 seconds before subject
2's neck is severed subject 1 vocalizes
acute distress and runs towards the test
chamber door subject 1 attempts to
bludgeon the door open unsuccessfully
for five seconds before turning around
and saying presumably to a perceived
entity no get away
subject one begins suffering lacerations
across the abdomen and tore
movement laceration and vocalization
cease simultaneously after seventeen
point three seconds autopsy on expired
subjects revealed two different
laceration patterns the relatively few
lacerations suffered by subject two are
consistent with lacerations caused by
three sharp objects approximately 27
centimeters in length and 8 centimeters
in maximum width while the many
lacerations suffered by subject 1 are
consistent with lacerations caused by
three sharp objects approximately 14
centimeters in length and 3 centimeters
in width note we still don't know
whether the entities are actually there
or illusions caused by a CP 178 but now
we know that they can affect more than
the wearer this means that this object
is potentially much more dangerous than
we initially surmise interestingly
enough the two subjects showed different
laceration patterns as though they were
inflicted by different entities a shame
we didn't ask subject 1 about the number
of entities in the room we'll do better
next time
it is also possible that subject
wouldn't have been harmed if she hadn't
addressed the entities herself that's
also worth checking out
experiment 178 e6 named dr. with doctors
and doctors assisting date 19 procedure
2 d-class subjects are to be placed in
secure test chamber containing a CP 178
the test chamber is to be observed by a
bulletproof glass window to adjacent
control room via audio and video
recording devices via infrared cameras
electromagnetic radiation sensors and
motion detectors both subjects will have
general knowledge of the properties of
SCP 178 one subject designated subject
one will be instructed to wear a CP 178
and will describe to the other subject
designated subject to the location and
appearance of any perceived entities in
the test chamber subject 2 will then
attempt to interact with the entities
subject one will be instructed not to
speak or otherwise interact with
entities at any eventualities
to ensure this subject one will be told
that any attempt to make contact with
the entities will result in termination
results subject 1d eight three six one
six male 44 no discernible mental
abnormality and subject to D three six
one seven six male 52 no discernible
mental abnormalities are placed in the
test chamber subject one is instructed
to wear a CP 178 subject one
uncooperative subject one instructed
again to wear a CP 178 subject one
uncooperative subject to urges subject
one to cooperate for fear of punitive
measures subject one wears SCP 178 and
expresses surprise and disgust research
staff inquires as to the number of
entities subject 1 states
they're everywhere doc there's nine of
them here with us subject 1 then turns
to look at the bulletproof glass window
separating the test chamber from the
control room and states and there's
three in there with you look there's one
leaning right over your
see incident report 178 14 alpha for
more information notes
following the loss of all research staff
in incident 178 14 alpha the containment
protocols have been revised oh five
seven experiment one seventy eighty
seven name doctor with doctors assisting
date two thousand procedure d-class
subject is to be placed in secure test
chamber containing SCP 178 the test
chamber is to be divided into two
partitions in a five to one ratio with
the smaller portion containing the
chamber entrance separated by
bulletproof glass with a small hole in
the middle covered in steel mesh to
allow the passage of sound from one
partition to the other the test chamber
will be observed remotely via audio and
video recording devices by infrared
cameras electromagnetic radiation
sensors and motion detectors subject is
to be told of scp-172 nature and
instructed to wear SCP 178 and attempt
to communicate with entities on the
other side of the partition results
subject d13 six to seven male 52 rape
double homicide no discernible mental
abnormalities is placed in the test
chamber and instructed to wear SCP 178
subject expresses displeasure but
complies subject instructed to describe
what it perceives subject describes for
entities in the other partition subjects
states entities look docile two of them
jabbing the walls and the other two
looking at it through the glass research
staff inquires whether any entities are
present in the subjects partition the
subject looks around and replies that
none are present subject instructed to
attempt to communicate with the entities
subject expresses desire to get this
over with subject says presumably
towards the perceived entities hello can
you hear me
before recoiling suddenly research staff
inquires as to the reason the subject
recoiled
the subject replies that the Anthony's
have begun pounding the glass with their
upper appendages research staff inquires
whether they are succeeding in causing
any visible damage to the partition
subject replies they're not audio
recordings fail to pick up any sounds
apart from those emitted by the subject
research staff inquires whether the
subject can hear the entities pounding
on the partition subject appears
perplexed and replies to the negative no
changes occur for 10 minutes and 14
seconds research staff announces the end
of the experiment subject expresses
relief and removes SCP 178 placing it on
the floor testing chamber door opens and
to security personnel agent demand that
the subject comes with them presumably
to d-class cells subject turns towards
door and begins complying when
lacerations begin appearing across his
face torso and upper arms subject
vocalizes distress and both security
personnel recoil and emit expletives
agent radio is a containment breach
agent begins firing his weapon into the
chamber hitting and killing the subject
after 2.1 seconds of being lacerated
containment teams are mobilized to the
testing area and the sector goes into
lockdown searches are concluded after an
hour in four minutes without any
findings or further incidents and
lockdown is lifted SCP 178 is found
where subject d13 six to seven dropped
it
nope that could have been catastrophic
first time we get to experiment on a CP
178 and the whole sector goes into
lockdown
the brass aren't gonna be pleased I
think we should come up with some lower
risk experiments for the foreseeable
future
I guess anywhere that attempts to
establish contact with the entities can
die even after removing a CP 178 it's
interesting to note that agent suffered
no ill effect
despite firing at the entity I estimate
it's because he had only very limited
knowledge about the entities observed by
those who wear the item experiment 178
e8 named doctor
with doctors assisting date
mm procedure d-class subject is to be
placed in secured test chamber
containing SCP 178 and a video camera
connected to monitor the test chamber is
to be observed remotely via audio and
video recording devices via infrared
cameras electromagnetic radiation
sensors and motion detectors subject is
to be instructed to hold SCP 178 up to
the camera and report what it sees on
the monitor
the camera is both connected to the
monitor and to an external recording
device pending the success of the
experiment the research staff will
submit a request to view the recording
results subject d6 one two eight six
female 28 fifteen counts of grievous
bodily harm two counts of murder no
discernible mental abnormalities is
placed in the test chamber and
instructed to pick up SCP 178 and hold
it up to the camera
subject complies and holds SCP 178
proximately 20 centimeters from the
camera subject instructed to hold SCP
178 up to the camera so that it sees
through it subject inquires as to which
lens it should hold it to subject
instructed to hold the red lens up to
the camera
subject complies research staff inquires
whether the monitor displays anything
unusual subject replies to the negative
subject instructed to hold the blue lens
up to the camera
subject complies and reports that the
monitor still does not display anything
unusual subject instructed to put down
the camera and whereas EP 178 subject
complies subject vocalises acute
distress stumbling backwards while
staring at the monitor research staff
inquires as to the source of the
subjects distress subject reports three
entities crouched in front of the
monitor looking at it the subject
instructed to remove SCP 178 test ended
notes it would appear that either the
item functions similarly to ordinary
stereoscopic glasses and requires two
eyes or that the effect isn't merely
optic there's a way to test that
experiment 178 e9 named doctor with
doctors assisting date non-applicable
proposed
20 procedure d-class subject placed in
secure test chamber containing SCP 178
and a special mount containing two small
video cameras stimulating a pair of
human eyes connected to monitor that
splices both images together in
real-time to create an image similar to
the way stereoscopic site works test
chamber observed remotely via audio and
video recording devices via infrared
cameras electromagnetic radiation
sensors and motion detectors subject is
to be instructed to hold a CP 178 up to
the camera and report what he sees on
the monitor the camera is set to record
pending success the research staff will
submit a request to view the recording
test proposal awaiting approval by
personnel with level 4 clearance or
above
addendum three personnel with level four
clearance are urged to read incident
report 178 14 alpha reading incident
report 178 14 alpha is mandatory for all
personnel with level 4 clearance or
higher overseeing or approving
experiments with the item warning
failure to comply with addendum 3 is
grounds for disciplinary measures okay I
think that about does it for today thank
you all for listening if indeed you
still are and you were all dismissed
good bye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bashar Muslim wookie Jax Marik
Pierce M Hamlin Austin Thomas Aldridge
Desmond Hoskins Depp's McGee
dr. mortis Johnno Porter Cody tench
Tiber ball on sighs seven actual if you
would like a special thank you at the
end of each of my videos and some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash evolving
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you